burn with me
[Applause]
[Music]
overdue Doctor Who review and I get to
show off the coat this was sent to me
for my birthday by one of you lovely
folks so yeah I am that much closer to
getting the getting a full outfit put
together so yeah we're getting there
so let's get the promo in there cuz this
is a sponsored video this is brought to
you by radio versus the Martians the
McLaughlin group for nerds it's a
podcast which means it's free you don't
have to spend a single penny but you go
to radio verses of the Martians comm or
you look them up on your podcast
listening app of choice and you get to
hear Mike Gillis and Casey Doran talk
about all sorts of wonderful awesome
geeky nerdy stuff they they butt heads
sometimes they meld minds sometimes
they're on the same page sometimes
they're not
sometimes they're talking about Star
Wars sometimes they're talking about
Batman sometimes they're talking about
Arnold Schwarzenegger and going through
every single one of his movies that he
ever made on podcast LaVista baby as
part of the radio versus the Martians
feed check them out they're sponsoring
this video and it's good stuff
in any case time to talk about 42 from
series 3 so the last few stories that
I've covered have been a little bit
rough the Dalek two-parter Lazarus
experiment so now we have 42 is this a
full recovery is this a back to the show
at its best not quite it's better than
the last two though my memory of this
episode in general was that it was just
kind of there and kind of bland and
going back to it I was largely trying to
figure out if a if maybe I'd short sold
it and it was better than I remember
being and be trying to sort out whether
if it is what I remember it and just
kind of middling whether that's because
it's
overall just white noise bland or is it
basically good things and bad things
balancing out to a neutral and it's
basically that so there are there are
some surprisingly good parts of this
stuff that I'd forgot like one of the
few things that is really good is
something that it's stuck with me but
there is a little bit more than that I'm
going on here so this is the episode
where the doctor and Martha show up on a
ship that is hurtling towards a Sun and
is gonna crash into that Sun in 42
minutes which is where we get the title
from the title might also possibly be a
little bit very kind of weak
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
reference you know given that Douglas
Adams did used to write for Doctor Who
back in the day so it's rushing around
the ship trying to get things back in
order trying to get it
you know booted up and away but there's
also something else going on as
something appears to have taken over one
of the members of the crew and he begins
to burn people alive just by looking at
them so now we've got a monster we've
got a time limit how is it it's honestly
it's doing too many things at once it
this is a mash-up of several ideas that
did not need to be put into the same
story and they don't complement each
other they're not benefiting each other
so narrative Lee speaking there are the
two stories that don't quite marry well
there is the story of a ship falling in
real-time because that's how you know
long is left in the episode at the time
that that happens falling in real-time
in 42 minutes into the Sun that they've
got to get the mechanics working that
honestly that could have been your
entire show that where they're fighting
the clock they could totally get the
ship up and running if they had the time
do they can they that is enough that is
more than enough to base your episode
around and just the looming threat of
crashing into the Sun is plenty of
threat and
in that case the real time gimmick and
the countdown serves a purpose
unfortunately it has to share space with
a monster of the week
which doesn't benefit from the real time
gimmick and in fact in some ways
actively undermines it because we until
the the episode blatantly reminds you oh
yeah they're gonna crash into the Sun
you forget that the ticking clock is a
thing because this monster is is
wandering around and like I said they
don't inherently complement each other
like the situation was dire enough I
feel like what happened was and this
one's written by Chris Chibnall
by-the-by I feel like they couldn't
figure out any way to have things keep
getting worse other than to throw in a
monster and I think it suffers in some
ways from the same issues that Father's
Day does which is the scenarios
threatening enough adding a monster
didn't help that having been said the
monster they added is not bad certainly
conceptually however it feels very much
like it's ripping off the empty child
from the empty child and the doctor
dances so instead of a small child and a
gas mask saying are you my mummy we have
a fully grown man in a red helmet going
burn with me and similarly we also have
you know that the infection is spread
about and he can he can turn other
people into into what he is so it really
feels like it's ripping off the empty
child but the the thing is part of why
the empty child was so unsettling is
because it it gave this read as a small
child but because you couldn't see its
face and there was this absolute
contrast between what looks like it
should be innocent but you know it's
dangerous whereas like it's just a dude
lumbering around in this helmet thing
it's just it's not it's not unsettling
it can be intimidating I'm not sure that
it is but it could be but it's not
unsettling which is
what the empty child was and that
contrast being one that I can't get away
from doesn't do the thing any favors
there's also some of the other things
that they've that they've added into
again like all you need is just trying
to fix the ship and the and rather than
like having things break because it's
getting too hot they have to break
because the possessed person broke the
thing or there is the single stupidest
door security system in the world like I
I know they try and hand wave this away
in that they set up the security system
while drunk but like why would a system
even be calibrated in such a way that
you could even set this up in the first
place that there's like a bajillion
doors between them in the auxilary
engine which you know it's the kind of
thing you need access to that's why it's
there and the only way through is to
answer weird questions that are either
about certain individuals who in an
emergency may in fact be incapacitated
or like weird Pub Quiz type questions
and if you don't get a right on the
first try the entire system locks down
what I'm saying that's the stupidest
security system I have ever freakin
heard of and again like I know they try
and hand wave it away with a with a
drunk explanation but no no this is too
stupid this is too stupid this whole
thing and so mostly what I've been doing
up to this point is complaining so what
is good well there is undoubtedly the
single best moment of the whole thing
which is Martha and and another crew
name crew member gets stuck in an escape
pod
that gets jettisoned and it gets
jettisoned in the direction of the Sun
so now she's gonna hit that Sun before
the rest of the ship does and it's
pulling away and she's just looking
through this little porthole and she
sees the doctor
and he's yelling I'll save you but she
can't hear him and they have the sound
cut out and the doctor just shouting
I'll save you as he gets smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller and
there's no sound that's a great shot
that sells the die Ernest the loneliness
the dread of what Martha's facing that's
really fantastic and also Tennant gives
a really good performance in this what
he's called upon to do at some points I
don't love but he does it really well
the the whole thing with him almost
getting you know burned through from the
inside out and being possessed you know
he he sells the fear and the pain of
that very very well again I'm not sure
it's a plot turned that the thing needed
and I don't love it and again stupid
arbitrary obstacles he he pops out of
the ship for a hot second to like
basically push some buttons and pull
lever that just happened to be located a
little bit further than he can reach
reaching out the door again who designed
this ship like what huh I don't know
just move it like a foot closer to the
doorway so you can reach around and yeah
I should be able to give the ship or
reach around in an emergency that's what
I'm saying and now we'll see if this
video gets to monetize for that comment
who knows but at their I guys I slipped
into other Soviet the the cruise pretty
good the the overall the vibe of it it's
trying very much to be the general tone
to be evocative of the impossible planet
in the Satan pit right down to reusing
some of the visual elements such as the
spacesuit that the doctor goes outside
and and in fact has the same director so
it's and again it just adds to more of
this feeling more like a cobbled
together of retread concepts with a real
time gimmick slapped on them it is a
retread of impossible planet and Satan
pit from from a setting and general vibe
standpoint it is a retread of the empty
child and
doctor dances in the as far as the
monster goes and then they've just laid
this real time ticking clock on top of
that hoping that that would be like the
magic ingredient to elevate this beyond
just kind of being cobbled together but
it just doesn't um and again that this
episode is not bad for all the stuff
that I'm complaining about that does
pull it down but none of its like what's
wrong with you kind of stuff it's just
it's just not great and in the plot you
know regarding Harold Saxon that moves
forward a little bit a little bit with
Martha's mother people got annoyed with
me for failing to mention that the
Lazarus experiment but the thing is like
these episodes don't get redeemed for
the way that they feed into the into the
series arcs story that's gonna pay off
in the finale like I've told I've
explained before why I don't like the
mystery box format of just referencing
something over and over and over again
that we don't know what the heck it is
until the finale which in this case is
Harold Saxon so you know I I don't these
these episodes aren't helped by that for
me at least
so I guess that'll wrap it up I actually
I'm gonna be a little bit more negative
than I meant to be it it's fine is what
this episode is it's fine I have a
suspicion I'm gonna see a litany of
comments telling me how they really like
it and whatever which is also fine so
whatever your thoughts I'm 42 are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of stuff to do
buttons and links and patreon and links
to other stuff that I do social media
blah blah blah merch etc check them out
down below or don't if you don't want to
you don't have to because at the end of
the day folks you're the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]